[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone it's seven o'clock here in
the uk you are very welcome wherever
you're watching us
around the world this morning we're
still on the roadmap out of lockdown in
england but we've been delayed in
reaching that final destination
many of boris johnson's mps are asking
will we ever
really get there we'll dissect the pm's
decision to move so-called freedom day
to the 19th of july with the cabinet
office minister
michael go very shortly and we'll put
labour's argument to him that all of
this could have been avoided
if we've closed our border to india much
much
soon i've been banging on about that
haven't we for days also this morning
for you
how tweeting can be good for you this
sort of tweeting
joined by the man who says the daily
dose of birdsong is the secret to coping
with anxiety that's at 9 30
and then at 9 45 back of the net will
build up to friday's crucial euro 2020
match between england and scotland harry
redknapp joins us and he's going to be
talking through the highlights of the
tournament
so far it's tuesday the 15th of june
boris johnson sets a so-called terminus
date to remove
england's coveted restrictions but sky
news meets those
who wonder if we'll ever get to the end
of the road map
we can't really keep spawning because
there will come a time when we
will only be one of us left
harvesting a trade deal first details of
the uk's first
post-brexit agreement with australia
with concerns about
how it might impact farming
a worthy adversary president biden says
he hopes to work with vladimir
putin on areas where cooperation is in
the interests
of both the us and russia pandemic
pupils the nhs launches
specialist care to treat the rising
number of children suffering from long
covert missed tumors a warning that
10 000 fewer breast cancer patients
started treatment
in the last 12 months compared with the
previous year
good morning very hot yesterday hot to
stay the year so far with 29.7 celsius
85.5 fahrenheit at bushy park in
teddington
it might not be quite as hot today but
for many there's still lots of strong
sunshine to come
hi everyone a very good morning sir the
19th of july is the new date for your
diary that's when boris johnson says
he hopes to end all coveted restrictions
in england
it's now all about ramping up the
vaccine program with a warning that
easing limits next week could lead to
thousands more deaths
but some of his own back ventures are
questioning the move with many sectors
of the hospitality industry
describing it as a devastating blow and
uncertainty for some hoping to
tie the knot as laura bondock reports
we just thought we'd do it like a little
book the spare wedding invites can now
be sent
out cat and phil have already moved the
date
four times and they don't want any more
delay
because cat has terminal cancer i want
to be able to make that commitment
to phil whilst i am as well as i can be
and and feel to me as well that we are
married and that we're making a
commitment to each other for
whatever amount of time that we have
left together as a
as a married couple cat's diagnosis came
just two weeks after they got engaged
their
big day now much smaller but just as
longed for
it's hugely important i think certainly
to me both of us just
to be with friends and family and to
have a proper
wedding celebration i can't really keep
postponing because there will come a
time when we
will only be one of us left we're seeing
cases growing by about
64 per week and in the world the latest
guidance says
weddings can now go ahead with more than
30 guests
but social distancing stays and dancing
inside's not allowed
there'll be no dancing for another month
at the royal albert hall
staff here were braced for bad news
they've only managed four concerts this
year
and now have 60 million pounds of lost
revenue
i feel like we're the last industry to
be to be opened up and i think i just
felt
ah no another month another month of not
being able to do what we do we had james
blunt we had superman in concert we had
a strong man competition
i mean you know very royal avatar weird
and wonderful things
we'll have to now either cancel or
reschedule most of those
everyone in hospitality is struggling
nathan clark runs brutal social club an
iconic music venue
in leeds it's not only about survival
it's about recovery
and the recovery is going to be the
biggest thing and i think the thing that
all of hospitality will be calling out
for
is an actual plan extensions to
the vat deferrals extensions to the rent
moratorium
the four-week delay allows more time for
vaccination
and ministers hope restrictions will
then be lifted for good
in the meantime though for many it's yet
another month of uncertainty
lost business and lost income laura
bundock sky
news delighted to say the cabinet office
minister michael gove is with me now
hello good morning good morning
um labor says you should have moved at
lightning speed to close the borders
uh with india as you did with pakistan
and bangladesh
um you didn't because of a trade uh deal
photo op
with the pm of india that's true isn't
it according to jonathan ashworth
well that's what jonathan says but
actually it's not true no um
we closed our borders we put india on
the red list
at the earliest appropriate opportunity
on the basis of all the evidence that we
had
in fact we put india on the red list
before
we knew that this delta variant was a
variant of concern you say that
however looking at the uh test and trace
figures
for the 25th of march the 7th of april
india was a bigger concern than
bangladesh
and yet you put bangladesh on the red
list but not india we put bangladesh and
pakistan on the red list and that's
because the advice at the time
from the joint bi-security center the
team of experts who helped us to
determine
when action should be taken was that the
positivity rate
of those coming from pakistan and
bangladesh merited that
and then of course we subsequently put
india on the red list but when we did
put india on the red list
uh it was the case that delta variant uh
wasn't then a variant under
investigation
never mind a variant of concern
according to the figures you know india
is the middle one
of these bars and bangladesh was put on
the red list india was not and these are
your own tests and trace figures
yes but there was a higher positivity
rate um overall for
people coming from pakistan and
bangladesh and it's important to
remember
that even before india was put on the
red list anyone arriving from india
had to self-isolate for 10 days
quarantine at home
in order to ensure that they weren't
spreading the vibes yeah quarantine at
home is very different to quarantining
in a hotel of course
isn't it and a lot of people either
quarantine at home with
other family members there or don't
quarantine at all
yes and of course one of the reasons why
we put india on the red list was to have
even stricter measures
but of course it is the case that
there's been enforcement of uh
home quarantine so when people have
breached those rules they have been
fined
um and it's very important that everyone
uh
appreciates that there are enforcement
measures in place and it is the case
that uh
when advice was given to matt and to the
rest of us in government
that we took the appropriate action and
the idea that um
the prime minister would put the
nation's health at risk because of
official opportunity
um with any other prime minister is just
for the birds so you completely
um as far as labor is concerned making
that allegation saying it was a trade
deal photo op
absolute nonsense total rubbish do you
regret
with the benefit of hindsight we love
2020 hindsight do you think we should
have put india on the red list earlier
well it's always the case that uh uh
people use hindsight and it's become
a labor's preferred method of viewing
all decisions
um but i think that we can only act on
the basis of the evidence that we have
at the time
okay so looking back do you wish that
you'd put them on the
red list earlier well given that we know
what we know now and the fact that the
numbers are doubling every week
with perfect hindsight there are many
many things that we've done in the past
that i've done in the past that i
wouldn't have done at the time
um well you can only
well that's another interview you can
only act on the basis of the information
you have at the time
okay um one of the reasons uh put
forward that people
don't isolate or haven't isolated always
up until now is the unsatisfactory
isolation payments
should we look again at compensating
people for staying at home
because they're going to work because
they need the money yeah absolutely
um i think the isolation payments work
but we keep everything under review
and it is the case that we provide
support for people who do have to
self-isolate
um and whether there is an impact on
their income
uh but again one of the things that we
seek to do is to make sure
that we take decisions that balance
support for individuals
with making sure that we keep others
safe as well do you acknowledge that
it we perhaps do need to look at that
again that there isn't enough money
which is why people are breaking you
know they don't want to go to work they
just need the money well we keep things
under review um and
uh if there is evidence um then we'll
look at it but the evidence so far
is that people understand the need for
quarantine or
self isolation and that people the
overwhelming majority are law abiding
and
understand the the requirements that the
government has reluctantly put in place
19th of july terminus day um
are we finally finally finally going to
see the end of these restrictions on the
19th of july or is it just the
end of the tram stop and we go around
again no that that will be the terminus
date
um you did say that about the 21st of
june to be fair well to be fair
what we said is that um we won't uh lift
those restrictions before
the 21st of june in there in the roadmap
it says not before
and the whole point about the roadmap
was to build in a an element of
flexibility and caution
and what we want to do is to and it is
regrettable
um that we do have this pause before
moving to step four but what we want to
do is to make sure that when we do make
that move
um that um we don't go back because the
worst thing for business
the worst thing for any of us would be
to open up again
um and then to very quickly find that we
had to re-impose restrictions
so what has to happen on the 19th of
july for us to
not uh extend further well
we believe that uh the vaccination
program which has been a big success so
far
can successfully vaccinate um an even
higher proportion
of the adult population we can make sure
that those who've been vaccinated once
get that second vaccine
and that we extend right the way down
the population range
and we hope by so doing that we can
limit the risk of infection and also
reduce the number of people going into
hospitals
and putting a strain on the nhs okay let
me put it another way what has to happen
on the 19th of july for us to
consider extending further well it would
require i think an
unprecedented and remarkable alteration
in the progress of the disease because
it has been described as hotel
california we can check out any time we
like but we can never leave these
restrictions that we find
ourselves in you're saying come the 19th
of july we will definitely be
able to unlock and go about our business
yes and to be fair even through the
restrictions that we still have
at the moment are are difficult um
there are a significant range of
activities that people can now
undertake believe me you know i'd love
to get rid of all of the restrictions
but i think it's important that we
maintain a sense of proportion um and so
there are some particular sectors of the
economy
that you know there are uh under greater
degree of pressure
but the economy overall is is performing
well
um and many of the things that we hold
dear um we can now do as a result of
uh the success of the vaccination
program and the progress that we've
already made
two and a half billion pounds worth of
rent debt already
in the uh hospitality sector oh they're
gunning for you guys they are not at all
happy um they cannot open for at least
um another
five weeks what would you say well it is
the case that we've already provided
support for the hospitality sector and
it is the case of course
um that venues can open in a covered
secure way
but um you know both of us i think would
like nothing more
and to be able to uh stroll to the bar
order a drink
uh uh gossip with friends um and and
socialize as we
we have in the past but we need to
exercise degree of caution it is the
case now
that you and i could uh go to dinner we
could enjoy table service
uh we could catch up on um mutual
friends and so on so social life
can continue albeit under restrictions
um and i think it's important that the
hospitality sector
is supported but i also think it's
important that we don't have a situation
where we open up
and then close down again i think the
hospitality sector would find that the
most difficult thing of all
more financial support for the
hospitality sector well the financial
support that the chancellor's already
put in place
was intended to take account of of any
um
slippage in the date from the 25th first
of july and then
um the uh furlough scheme starts to
taper off from the first of july doesn't
it
we're we're asking employers to play a
um a bigger role in the first
massive debts they need your support but
the system that we have is more generous
than
um most similar countries um and it's
also
that doesn't help the people that are
struggling does it happen
it's still the case that there will be
further support until the end of
september
um but we're just asking employers to
pay um
a a little bit of that furlough support
and that's entirely in line with what
other countries that have been going
through
perhaps even greater difficulties are
doing as well so although we're
extending to the 19th of july there
won't be any more money than what's
already been announced
uh well the chancellor deliberately
decided to go long in terms of financial
support
that's why furlough is there that's why
other support is there into the autumn
so in answer to my question there won't
be any more money than what's already
been announced
what we've already announced the
chancellor and i i think he's
right has calculated will help support
the economy
and all the evidence is that the the
economy is performing better
um than many feared okay um when should
school children um have uh their jobs i
think that's ultimately a matter for
uh the jcvi and for um medical experts
to advise us on but you'd be very happy
for your kids to have theirs as soon as
uh or i would follow medical advice yeah
okay masks in schools um
they have been scrapped um should that
be reconsidered given that
we've seen the virus spreading amongst
kids well it's spreading amongst young
people who haven't been vaccinated
but i think at every point we have to
make a judgment you know yes case
numbers are rising but it's also the
case that
uh even though many restrictions are
still in place others have been lifted
for example on weddings
um and and the key thing is that we want
to get life back to normal
as quickly as possible but we have to
exercise a degree of caution
so we can have some progressive
relaxations um and i think that they're
they're balanced against the need to
preserve public health um staycations
only way forward we're told this year by
many of your colleagues that have been
sat there over the last week or so you
did go
to um the euros in portugal you got
pinged sadly yes
uh has that meant that you're thinking
twice about going overseas
yes i haven't made any holiday plans
yet okay but i'm guessing you're not
going to be heading to the scottish
hills or the uh welch hills because
this news well probably will be going to
school well you say that because this
new soup to nuts trade deal with
australia the the farmers are not at all
happy
in the united kingdom they feel that
aussie farmers having unfettered access
to um across our borders with their lamb
supplies will
cause all sorts of problems well we
support farmers um
and we do so not just by providing them
with uh
direct financial support but also by
making sure that we
uh give them an opportunity to export
their fantastic produce on the world
stage and i actually think
that we should be confident about the
quality of the produce that uh
our farmers are responsible for i think
that uh
uh opening up new markets for them
worldwide which is what the
brilliant trade secretary this trust is
doing is the way to make sure
that we can um not only keep our farmers
successful
but also ensure that we have investment
in the countryside so you're not worried
that
as they are about uh the aussie lamb
flooding into the united kingdom and
there being no market for the uk lamb
well i'm like i personally am a great
fan of um welsh lamb
and i think that uh consumers will be
free to make that choice but i think it
is also worth pointing out that the
majority of of
of meat um which is reared and raised in
australia
goes to the asian market um and that is
their principle and growing
market um but overall um you know
australia
is a friend and ally um
and i think that you know they've been
one or two points that have been made
about australia during the course of
this debate
that mischaracterize um uh uh how
australian farmers operate
um and the opportunities also for uk
farmers so
it's important that we maintain
protections and support for farmers
but it's also the case that opening up
trade barriers provides or rather
bringing them down and opening up new
opportunities
uh provides our farmers with a chance to
uh to show on the world stage
the amazing quality of uk projects okay
i want to put this to you finally if i
may i need to read my notes because i
want to be precise um the high court has
uh found that you broke the law last
week uh in your department's awarding of
a 500 000
contract to public first which was run
by your friend and former special
adviser james
frey that's a breach of the ministerial
code matt hancock acted unlawfully
uh over pandemic contracts we're told
there was evidence that pretty patel
broke the code in dealing with
her staff as well um what do you have to
do to get punished in the cabinet
well the first thing to say is that the
decision to award that contract was not
my decision
i'm very happy to defend it because we
were operating under pressure
at a time when uh this pandemic requires
us to act
with speed and it's important also to
see um that the
the court didn't find any evidence that
um i had tried to
uh influence this particular contract um
and what we were doing
um across government at that time was
responding to
a very very challenging situation um and
uh the court found that there was no
actual bias in the decision that was
taken by others to award this contract
but acting with speed doesn't mean that
you can breach the ministerial code
there was no breach of the ministerial
code
sure yeah so when we come back to this
in
a month's time you're absolutely
standing by that absolutely
okay fantastic just before i let you go
how disappointed are you that you didn't
manage to go to the g7 they looked just
so they were having a whale of a time
uh i was having an even better times in
northern ireland
um i was there for the british irish
council
um so it was an opportunity for me to
say thank you to arlene foster the
departing first minister of northern
ireland
and cornwall is lovely but fermana i
think is even nicer and that was better
than a barbecue on the beach
uh yes we had a very nice um dinner with
um
northern ireland produce um from uh
lockhart eel to uh local beef and
um i'd recommend to anyone if they're
wondering where to go on holiday
um this summer and uh cornwall is booked
then try northern ireland okay good to
talk to you i have to let you go good
chat forever
uh i really do want to come back again
though yeah some of the things that
you you don't want to talk about um
today not least what things that you've
regretted doing in the past
okay okay but we'll probably take us a
couple of hours okay we can clear the
schedule
okay it's no problem at all thanks so
much indeed thanks thank you
with me one second still to come on the
program for you
as the 30 guest limit is lifted for
weddings what difference will that make
for those
tying the knot we'll speak to one couple
now
hurriedly rearranging their plans that's
just after
half past seven why are so many
businesses struggling to recruit staff
during the economic downturn
uh chef mitch tonks is desperate for new
recruits and joins us at around
7 35 8 20 will get the thoughts of the
shadow health secretary
jonathan ashworth on the delay to
lockdown easing in
england just what we've heard also from
michael gove within the last
few moments
but before all of that the latest
unemployment figures um
have just been released figures to april
show there was a decrease
in the unemployment rate to 4.7 percent
the number of people
working increase for the sixth
consecutive month up by 197
000. also making the news for you
this morning just talking about the
britain and australia
announcement expected very shortly
they've agreed a post brexit trade deal
we believe the prime minister held final
talks over dinner
with the australian leader scott
morrison in downing street last night
both sides say they hope to increase
trade between the two countries
above the current level of 20 billion
pounds
24 hours before he meets vladimir putin
president biden has told
nato leaders the alliance is key to
confronting the threat posed by russia
ahead of the meeting in switzerland mr
biden said the russian leader was
someone who could be an adversary
ten thousand fewer patients in england
started treatment for breast cancer in
the last year
a study by cancer research uk suggests
the delay is partly due to
women staying at home due to concerns
about contracting covid19
we think that kovid has really added to
some of the barriers that people
have already about seeking help and
they're worried about overburdening the
nhs
i can understand why that's the case but
their health is important
and if they've noticed anything unusual
about their house
a change to their body then i really
would encourage them to make contact
with their gp
and if they have trouble getting that
appointment to keep trying
current and former bbc bosses will
appear before mps this morning to
explain the corporation's handling
of martin bashir's interview with the
princess of wales
a recent investigation concluded the
reporter acted in a deceitful way
and faked documents to persuade the
princess to take part
despite an explosion and a huge fire
emergency services say
no one was injured in this place in the
american state of illinois
an evacuation was ordered around a
chemical factory in the town of rockton
which is the largest producer of greece
in the united states
nhs is launching specialist services to
treat the rising number of children
and young people suffering from
so-called long covet
let's talk about it in more detail
shaman freeman powell joining us now
from the newsroom hello can you tell us
more
yeah well there has been growing
concerns about young people who say that
they've experiencing these long-lasting
effects of covid19 and the truth is is
that there's still
a lot that we don't understand about
long-covid
and while young people and children are
less likely to suffer from severe
disease
according to the office of national
statistics around 13
of under 11s and around 15 of 12 to 16
year olds
reported at least one symptom five weeks
after the
initial confirmed covid19 infection
and this is quite serious because some
of the symptoms range from fatigue
to chest pains to serious impacts on
people's mental health issues so these
hubs there will be 15 hubs set up around
the uk
there will be staff with experts on the
issues such as
respiratory symptoms and also
some of the fatigue and they will work
with families
and their gps to address the issues and
concerns that their families may have
and to try and support young people
because we must remember these will be
the last ones to be vaccinated so
a lot of money is being pumped into this
to these hubs to try and support these
young people
okay for now thanks
uh what's happening as far as the
weather is concerned it was glorious
yesterday what about today let's find
out here's kirsty kirsty good morning
more of the same
a little bit more of the same okay not
as hot as yesterday we got
29.7 celsius that's 85.5 fahrenheit in
bushy park in teddington that's the
middlesex
that was very hot making hottest day of
the year so far temperatures just
a little bit lower today let's take a
look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning uh weatherfront through
went through last night which means
we've got a legacy of cloud towards the
southeast this morning
and that means it won't be quite as hot
today as it was yesterday
and up to the northwest looking very
different indeed wet and
windy weather moving in here but for
mainly it will be a largely dry day with
some
lovely smells of strong summer sunshine
and we'll lose that low clouds in the
southeast it will brighten up here as
well but temperatures peaking
more like 25 or 26 so not the near 30 we
saw yesterday
but high very high uv levels and high or
very high grass pollen to watch out for
slightly cooler in the north and west as
wetter and windier weather
moves in here during the day
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
coming up in just a moment or two we're
going to be speaking to one couple
trying
to work out what new wedding rules mean
for them
as they get ready for their big day
[Music]
[Applause]
this monastery is under the protection
of russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
they can't arrest everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm skye's chief
correspondent
when enormous explosion it's just come
down
we saw snatch what's going in grabbing
people
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a walk let's do it
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change we take
you to the heart of stories
that shape our world they were convinced
the united states would become hooked
[Music]
we hear shotguns being fired
withdrawn it's so so hot
my name is fatima zaziler the founder of
ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
[Music]
exchange if you recycle to get a tree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
done
hello again the government says it's
confident lockdown restrictions in
england will be eased on the 19th of
july following a decision to extend them
for up to four
more weeks short time ago the cabinet
office minister michael gove told this
programme
he believed the rules would be eased
next month
that that will be the terminus date um
you did say that about the 21st of june
to be fair
well to be fair what we said is that um
we won't
uh lift those restrictions before the
21st of june in there in the roadmap it
says
not before and the whole point about the
roadmap was to build in
a an element of flexibility and caution
and what we want to do is to
and it is regrettable um that we do have
this pause before moving to step four
but what we want to do is to make sure
that when we do make that move
um that um we don't go back because the
worst thing for business
the worst thing for any of us would be
to open up again
um and then to uh very quickly find that
we had to re-impose
restrictions what has to happen on the
19th of july for us to consider
extending further
well it would require i think an
unprecedented
and uh remarkable alteration
in the progress of the disease
well our political correspondent
tomorrow cohen is joining us now so
that's not
definitely a no tomorrow or is it to
extending further
well i think michael gove like boris
johnson yesterday kaye
is very keen to project the idea that
they're very
confident that if we just ease off the
accelerator a bit
that in four weeks time when two-thirds
of the adult population
will have been fully vaccinated then we
will be in the best position
to fight off the indian variant which
has seen
a very large growth in cases over the
last
couple of weeks and a rise now in
hospitalizations
and then be able to open up fully boris
johnson keeps using this word
irreversible he wants the end of
lockdown to be irreversible
and if it couldn't be irreversible by
loosening restrictions
in england on the 21st of june then we
need to wait
up to another four weeks now to be fair
the government scientists were also
pretty confident that with
lots more vaccines going into people's
arms by that stage
we would be in a better place to throw
off
all the social distancing restrictions
but there is some concern
about the prime minister's continued use
of this word irreversible
he wants to give people to give
businesses certainty
but sir patrick valance said yesterday
that we would be living with covid
forever and that's why we saw a number
of tory mps
pretty angry in the house of commons
yesterday saying
that they expected there will be more
restrictions in winter
perhaps into next year and that perhaps
this lockdown
would effectively never end there are
also more questions for the government
about why
india was not put on the red list
earlier given
the problems that have been caused by
the indian variant
and whether more variants could come in
and as michael go suggested
as a remarkable event derailed that date
once more today labour are calling for
all the ambulance countries to be put on
the red list instead
to give a clear signal that foreign
travel should not be taking place
okay tomorrow for now thanks so much
since mr gove did
also said there wouldn't be any more
money in addition to what has
already been announced by the chancellor
for the hospitality industry despite the
fact that they
are going to find themselves having to
be closed for another month longer than
anticipated
no great surprises when the pm announced
that lockdown easy measures were being
delayed for that
four weeks but one piece of good news
was that couples getting married
will be able to have more than 30 guests
but they won't be able to set foot
on the dance floor or to sing hayley
smith and marcus knight
are less than a week away from their big
day and they are with us now hello to
you both
hello good morning hey good morning good
morning talk to me about how anxious you
were when you were listening to the
prime minister speaking last night
i mean probably about as anxious as
we've been for the last
what year trying to plan to plan the
wedding we're on our fourth date now
and um it doesn't get any easier no it's
if
every time we've had to move it it's
just been more and more stressful
and um we we knew he wasn't going to
move it again
but the um the anxiety of having to
drill down your guest list isn't fun
no i'm sure so you can you can have more
than 30 people
but they can't dance and they can't sing
how does that make you feel
well we love a good boogie so it's quite
hard for us to process and
the same with a sing-song but um but for
us what makes things even more
complicated is we have an outdoor
venue and so the rules around that seem
a bit
bit cloudy as to what can happen because
it says that while not illegal
i think outdoors it says it's just not
advised um
and there doesn't seem to be a lot of
clarities you know there seems to be
some rules that are contradictory about
you can't have a standing up reception
indoors or outdoors but these other
rules for outdoor weddings seem to be
okay so
at the moment we're still a bit in the
dark about what we can proceed with
when he got down on one knee to propose
did you ever think
did you ever think that you would have
to go through all of this pallava in
order to tie the knot
absolutely not it's been the longest
engagement ever yeah it certainly felt
that way
um i mean you know surely it shows our
level of commitment
um but no i mean no no one could ever
guess is you know planning a wedding is
is difficult uh you know the best of
training yeah if you know for any couple
at any
any time but but this has just been
unbelievable and you know every time
we've had to reschedule the wedding it's
not just about
moving a date it's about making sure
that all your suppliers are available
for that day
it's trying to move it without you know
costing more money and every time it
just comes with us a great degree of
sort of stress and uncertainty
and it just feels that everything else
is put on hold until the wedding happens
so we're sort of
in a constant state of limbo and um
it's just uh yeah it's it's not been
great on our mental health
no i'm sure that's true i'm sure that's
true
why did you decide to keep uh
planning the date why didn't you wait
until we were
totally out of lockdown
well i mean we did so you know we
thought this would be it
yeah so we you know we moved it and we
moved it and like say you know every
time it's been really really hard on our
sort of mental health to
stick with it but you know we wanted to
have the wedding the way we wanted to do
it for us it was all about
having friends there is about having a
big party a big celebration
so that's why we moved it back four
times
three times to a fourth day and um and
so that's
sort of the gutting blow that you know
even though we've decided it's
the best thing for us to proceed ahead
no matter what and obviously with the
actual guests it's great but
we're still not sort of getting the
wedding we had planned for and that's
that's a little bit
hard to to process so what have you got
planned then
for the wedding um
well with my sit-down meal winter boys
yeah we get married in a forest
um it all depends on the restrictions
now because we have things like lawn
games
um we have um an illustrator there um
we've got some music live music
so it really does depend on on what the
restrictions are but
um it'll be a lot of fun still and
we are really still looking forward to
it um it's just
getting through the confusion now of
what we can and can't do
and how many people have you got coming
along to help celebrate your big day
um about 70 to 80. amazing amazing
yeah which is perfect so when you before
you heard what the prime minister said
last night were you sort of hovering
over the guest list with a big red pen
we've been doing that for the past
couple of weeks yeah yeah and it's
i'm you know and we we're glad you know
we're glad we'd never had to make that
decision
um because it's just you know it's
difficult it's difficult there's there's
all these people that you want there and
that means so much to you and to be able
to say sorry
you can't come or even just sorry you
can't come and you know bring plus ones
and things like that but you know i
guess we would have had to have found a
way
to deal with it but yeah thankfully now
at least that's just we can have all the
people there
apart from people that are coming in
internationally because obviously that's
still a big issue and you know my my
sister's in florida
and her family and so they won't be able
to come to the wedding and so this is
just another
area of you know problems that we've had
to deal with in regards to uh
people being able to attend the wedding
i understand the challenges that it's
been
uh on both of you haley and marcus but
it's just one day it is an important day
for the rest of your life but then it is
a signal that you're spending the rest
of your lives together and you'll be
able to see your family and friends and
you'll be able to
introduce your babies to the family in
the fullness of time so enjoy the day
and be safe in the knowledge that it's
the first day of the rest of your lives
together
exactly exactly for us it's the day
where we can it's it's the first day
past the pandemic for us isn't it like
from this point we can we can truly move
on and it's just a day of celebration
see everybody celebrating us with our
loved ones okay
don't tell me what the dress is going to
look like but i bet you're going to look
absolutely as my son would say
banging it's lovely to see you both
thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot thank you so much take care
just gives you an idea of the sort of
levels of stress that young people like
that have had to go through
during the last 18 months well following
the least release of the latest
unemployment figures
there's concern amongst businesses about
the rising vacancy rate that's the
increasing number of jobs that can't be
filled
even during the economic downturn and
why is that let's
try and find out mitch tonks runs eight
seafood restaurants in devon and
dorset and he's with us now hi mitch
how are you i am very well tell me the
sort of challenges that you're facing at
the moment trying to recruit staff
well we're in a kind of a strange time
in the summer seems to have come
very early to us in the southwest so
we're inundated with customers
and we are across our eight restaurants
120
people short from running them at full
full tilt so our teams are under a lot
of pressure
um to deliver customers quite naturally
want to get out after being locked down
and we're seeing applications really
slow to the rates that they normally
were
would um what has the last year been
like for you and your staff because it's
been
you know it's been very hit and miss you
didn't know you you opened i'm sure you
did
um help out eat out to help out uh in
august and then everything was locked
down again
and then we were open then we weren't so
what sort of impact has it had
well i mean the first couple of weeks
were really challenging while we were
trying to work out
whether we could survive how we would
get through it and work a strategy for
that but actually during the year
i think we kind of use the time wisely
to sort of um reevaluate our business to
make it better for our customers and our
staff
and actually it was a very positive time
and then last year we had
a bumper summer which was really really
good and
i think we would have finished the year
pretty good if it hadn't been for the
second lockdown so it's definitely been
tough on staff but we've made a real
point of kind of keeping in touch with
people and keeping everybody engaged
why is it so difficult to fill the
vacancies i mean i think you're looking
at what 25 vacancies
at the moment in your business well we
across the eight restaurants when we
when we get to the summer we'll be 123
people so it's quite a lot
and uh but normally we don't start
recruiting um for the summer until
around sort of
april time so i think it's just a set of
circumstances of people
um wanted to come on holiday earlier
enjoying the sunshine wants to get out
and we're on the kind of upward trend
but at the upward sort of
um recruitment cycle and i think that
there are a lot of businesses down here
that are looking so there's a lot more
competition
um i think people have had a year off
and or a year locked up and they're
actually thinking they may have
sort of re reevaluated life and their
priorities and
therefore perhaps want to summer off
universities haven't broken up yet
and i generally think the situation will
start to free
um as you know maybe maybe furlough ends
and people start to move around looking
for jobs but
i think it's a temporary situation but
frustrating for all of us
yeah i'm sure that's true the extension
to the 19th
of july terminus day we're now calling
that
what impact is that going to have on you
and your business
i think we're all looking forward to
getting back to normal taking masks off
and
you know i i don't think we're going to
start putting lots more chairs back into
restaurants we're going to sort of keep
it
the pace that it is but i think
everybody was just looking forward to
kind of like
this is normality now and it's really
great so it's a little bit of a
you know wading intrigue a little bit
sticky and um but it'll be okay but i
just really feel for like
you know nightclub businesses and pubs
that just haven't been able to open and
you know lots of celebrations i think
that's the biggest impact we have lots
of people booking
bigger tables at this time in our
private dining rooms um
ready to kind of do some family
celebrations and now this week they're
all gonna have to be cancelled so that's
frustrating for them
yeah uh mitch i'm interested to hear you
say that you're not gonna add more
tables back again why is that
i think it's one of the things that we
learned in uh in long term that we
we just gave people a better time and
the dining rooms are in a much better
rhythm
um we can actually give better service
people have more space
and and i think that was one of the
mantras that we used during lockdown was
let's emerge from this a better business
and i think that was part of it
um and as far as uh your area is
concerned i was down there
um over the weekend for g7 beautiful
parts of the world what would you say
to people who are watching this morning
who are thinking about heading
um to your area for a staycation this
summer
well you're coming to paradise i mean i
you know people are heading down here
because i think devon and cornwall
are two of the most beautiful counties
in the uk wonderful coastlines
and the one thing i'd say is that if
you're going to a hospitality venue
you know um try and just understand that
everybody is desperately trying to do
their best
serve huge numbers and probably doing it
with less resource than they
than they had so a level of
understanding for for everyone in the
industry will be really good
indeed so make sure yeah and make sure
you tip your waiting staff
mitch it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed thanks a lot
i would highly rather buy i would highly
recommend it a beautiful beautiful part
of
the world um coming in just a few
moments why 10 000
fewer patients have started treatment
for breast cancer in the last year
we'll speak to one woman who's been
affected coming next
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
we take you to the heart of the story
that shapes our world
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
[Music]
yes
[Music]
there's anger at the police under the
government
it was from this chamber the carlos
fujimon declared independence in october
i want to show other people what
happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm skye's
europe correspondent
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores
but simply into british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system
will be able to cope
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier
i have no time for any polymix
[Music]
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
lay i am tonitiv the founder and the ceo
of renewables in africa this picture
changed my whole career
and my whole life my mission is simple
to bring back power to africa
and our aim is to turn the dark
continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
2014.
[Applause]
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
today will be fine and warm for many
wetter and windier
in the northwest a rather gray start in
the southeast but the cloud here will
thin
and break and for much of england and
wales it'll be sunny and
warm not as hot as yesterday up to 25 or
26.
cloudier and cooler to the north and
west as outbreaks of rain moving
across scotland northern ireland and the
republic and the winds pick up as well
grass pollen levels are now high to very
high across england and wheels
rising to moderate across northern
ireland and scotland
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
now maradona was regarded as one of the
world's greatest footballers
and so organisers of one of south
america's biggest football tournaments
decided
to pay a big tribute to him last night
and it looked like this
officials revealed this ahead of
argentina's copa america match against
chile the player's life was celebrated
with a hologram show
featuring images of maradona throughout
his career there we go
and his number on his shirt as well on
the ground he's is he going to score
that girl of course he is
he never really missed did he
you go now leading cancer charity
is warning that 10 000 fewer
breast cancer patients have started
treatment in england this year because
of a backlog caused by the pandemic
the number of deaths from breast cancer
in this country had reached an all-time
low
before the lockdown joining us is breast
cancer survivor and campaigner
helen addis hello to helen
hi kay how are you good morning good
morning lovely to see
you first of all just remind us about
your story
so it was three years ago when i found
um
my lump and you know i was 39 years old
no family history
of breast cancer so i actually wasn't
worried i thought it was something
hormonal went to see my gp
um who agreed yeah there's a lump there
but it's likely to be a hormonal but
let's
um get you to see the breast consultant
two weeks later i saw the breast
consultant and another four lumps are
grown
um so that just goes to show how fast my
cancer
was actually going which is why today's
news
um absolutely horrifies me that
that uh you know there's such a delay in
people starting
their treatment because had my
treatment been delayed outcome well i
know my outcome would have been
extremely
different and they moved me very quickly
into treatment
which was you know ultimately
life-saving
yeah so if if you had got your lumps
this time now then you probably wouldn't
be with us anymore
well exactly because there is such
a backlog now and people are having
treatment delayed uh treatment
cancelled i've actually only just i'm
i'm
recovering at the moment from my
reconstruction which should have
happened over a year ago
but that was delayed due to covid
thankfully though you know
reconstruction isn't
life-saving surgery so i can understand
why that was delayed but
um you know it just goes to show the
knock-on effect that's happening right
now
there has been so much research into
breast cancer and fewer people dying of
breast cancer now than any other time
in history in the united kingdom but i
suppose
you and many other women and men are
going to be anxious
that given what's happened over the last
12 18 months
that the research is not there as it
used to be
absolutely i think that we have made
great headway and we can't forget that
breast cancer
is the most diagnosed cancer within um
women and we just you know the thing
that really gets me is that
covert is now seen as the big c whereas
actually
cancer to me and thousands of others
is really the the big c that is still
with us and
i cannot even begin to think the
ramifications that this is gonna cause
overcoming
over the coming years yeah and she
absolutely helen i mean
you work obviously to help women uh
support them during this incredibly
traumatic time um i'm guessing a lot of
women's mental health is suffering they
know that they have cancer they fear
that they have cancer and they can't do
anything about it
absolutely and um i have uh
lots of people within the within my
community that um
in fact one lady last week has gone in
um because she had a
cancer recurrence but she was have to
have to top
she had to be told the news on her own
because she wasn't allowed anybody
in the room with her you know she's 31
years old she's got a six-month-old
old baby and she's told that she's got
incurable cancer
um it's unimaginable and
even actually you know for the people
that haven't been able to have
reconstruction the the mental impact of
that
has been uh astronomical actually
um and i think that i think the cancer
community is feeling
very unloved right now and a little bit
uh forgotten about so what can the
government do to try to
make you feel that love again
i think we need to get the screenings
back up to speed um
i think that we need to be encouraging
people to be going back to their gps if
there's anything that they see
on their body that is unusual i think
people are still
still very scared about going to um
their gp if they notice anything
um and i just think that
there needs to be um yes some more
funding so that we can catch up
and get back on track to where we were
before
i love your wall light it's amazing
it's an official the titty gritty uh
wall light
which uh yes it's absolutely superb i
love it i want one i don't know where
you're going to get it from but i'll ask
you off there and i want one
it's lovely to speak to you helen thank
you so much i'm glad that you're on the
map
can i just say if anybody out there has
any lumps bumps
bleeding discharged from the nipples
please get it checked out just get it
checked out it's not likely to be
nothing but do get it checked out yes
you can and yes you did thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot
glad that it's ended well for helen just
had her reconstructive surgery
and all has gone well she won't be out
in the sun today though
hopefully although it is pretty sunny
for most of us isn't it
kirstie it is indeed we have got some
lovely sunshine to come today for
some of us it's not quite as hot as
yesterday
and actually although the heat will
return tomorrow we're looking at some
thunderstorms to end the week
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning yesterday was the hottest
day of the year so far temperatures
peaking at 29.7 celsius 85.5 fahrenheit
in tedington bushy park in titanton in
middlesex now it won't be quite as hot
today
a bit of cloud around first thing this
morning but still rather mild
much of england whales southern scotland
seeing the sunshine as the day goes on
but
out towards the north and west we are
seeing thicker clouds moving in
bringing with it some wet and windy
weather later on so temperatures in the
northwest near where they should be for
the time of year
still pretty warm towards the southeast
25 or 26 and of course strong sunshine
very high uv levels and very high grass
pollen for some of us as well
we'll keep an eye on the wet and windy
weather it will move its way
southward as we go through the night
tonight draped really from northern
england through the irish sea by the end
of the night
that's where we'll have more clouds and
spits and spots of rain coastal work
the southeast getting very hot again
tomorrow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways